the CBS News political contributors
Robby Mook and Terry Sullivan they're
here they know a thing or two about the
Iowa caucuses MOOC with Hillary
Clinton's 2016 campaign manager and
Sullivan was Senator Marco Rubio's
campaign manager that year gentlemen
good morning good morning so we don't
know the results we don't really know
why we don't have the results but we
know this is bad for the Democrats is
this the end of party run
caucuses like this in Iowa and elsewhere
I think it might be you know I think
it's time for us to really question
whether operatives should be running
these or actual election officials who
are real perfect for any party
operatives versus state employees exact
I think this needs to be left to the
pros and we're just seeing here right
now every vote should be cast and
counted and we're running into problems
where maybe the technology is an issue
or the ballots are an issue let's just
leave this to professionals my guess is
in New Hampshire you know this will be
this will be run very differently and
we'll know the answer well this was
supposed to be the big kickoff to the to
the campaign and we got we got nothing
here and candidates who were depending
on this for momentum are trying to have
to they're trying to make it up yeah
this is a total goat rodeo and it's I
mean rodeo rodeo absolutely it's kinda
crazy to watch but nobody knows what's
going on yeah at the end of the day the
real winner here the results are in is
Donald Trump yeah how is he not the
winner from this every front page of
every newspaper no longer has a
candidate's picture on it and their name
it has indecision in Iowa yes you see it
the White House today Terry they're
saying to the Democrats keep doing what
you're doing right well I think they've
been saying that for a while I mean you
know but you know what guys both Budaj
edge and Bernie Sanders are claiming
victory what do you make of that and how
can they both do that they're smart they
should be I mean why is that a smart
move Terry because they could tell you
make it who you like go out and declare
victory
early and then move and go on to New
Hampshire and then when they come out
and sit there with the results later
today and say oh well you were actually
in second place you know okay results
you don't yeah that's the point you can
know the results are now meaningless
meanwhile Robbie if I'm Mike Bloomberg
I'm thinking glad I didn't show up for
for Iowa yeah that might be true and
look I think this was good for Biden in
as much as we saw me
he was coming in third fourth place or
something like that now he's no place
and that's better
how is that good you know I think just
when when there's no twin that rank that
stack ranking doesn't appear if you were
lower on those tiers
it's the optics didn't look good for him
yesterday when you saw the actual
caucuses you saw the number of people
here and the number of people here you
go to Biden's case it was and crickets
and a lot of my internal numbers at the
Sanders campaign released showed by an
in fourth place yeah and I was speaking
to the Buddha judges people this morning
too and they said that they think that
they did really well so I but this is
the point we don't know and I think this
is why we gotta go to having the
professionals not the operatives running
this so how now do the Republicans
capitalize on this it seems to be
writing itself actually I actually so I
will say I think we're gonna get through
this and move on I think there are only
what five six caucus is left at all most
of these states were going into our big
primary stage we'll know the results
like this thing will start to move this
was we're in a state of suspense right
now you think it's gonna just move on I
mean it doesn't hurt the party when
you've got done and you're saying things
like these are the people who want to
run your health care you know I'm not a
political expert you guys are but that
sounds pretty effective yeah I mean this
is look this is a big blow for the
Democrat Party in the entire process yes
they screw up in Iowa how do we know
that New Hampshire is gonna be better
how do we know that South Carolina will
be right it's run by the party because
well in South Carolina it's run by the
state I believe and in New Hampshire as
well and O'Keefe I think it was who
talked to a campaign manager who said
the best thing to do right now is forget
Iowa even happened I mean nobody if I
were a campaign look you got to keep
moving forever you just got to move in
dwelling on this if you won you don't
want to dwell because we don't know if
you want if you did poorly you don't
want to dwell because maybe did poorly
you know just move on you would do that
- yeah absolutely go to New Hampshire
and focus on your Hampshire voters
that's only thing in the world that
matters today try to get some momentum
there because you can't get it in Iowa
I'll be much barry sullivan thank you
you